so now we're ready for the body of the
proof we've done lots of set up so that
this next part hopefully fingers crossed
we'll go relatively quickly so let's let
f of X here's the thing we're interested
in not just X cubed not just x squared
like any power of X so I'm calling it
exit power of M so that's a bit of a
messy end okay so what I'm gonna do is
write f dash X and I'm gonna use this
different way of working out the
derivative right it's really the same
it's just dressed up slightly
differently okay
so f dash X will equal right here we go
the limit as now normally I would say H
approaches zero but this time I'm gonna
use this odd the formant instantly
hopefully once we've written it down
you'll see why this other form is more
useful to us okay C approaches X right
so this is this other lens through which
we can look at the same diagram okay now
on the top I would normally have f of X
plus h take away f of X but I've got a
different way of looking at this so I've
got f of X take away F of C what's f of
X in this case just this guy right X to
the power of n what's F of C that's
everywhere you saw an X don't put an X
in there put C so it's gonna be take
away C to the power of n right there's f
of X there's f6 yep I'm gonna just write
that down so here's f of X right to say
F of C by definition it means everywhere
you saw an X in here don't don't put in
X put in C instead that's your function
notation back from the start of the year
okay so that used to be an X but I
swapped it out for a C said okay alright
there's our numerator what time oops
what's on the denominator it's just X
minus C right that's always the same no
matter what function you've got okay now
we went through all this algebraic work
over here so that we can come up with
this longer assault it looks really
gross right now but when we work with it
here you're going to see it's going to
come out
beautifully what what happens limit as C
approaches X because we always have to
write that out the front now this guy
here before we did our work this morning
there's nothing you can do with that
it's like what am I supposed to do with
this gross I have no idea how to
factorize it but you know how to
factorize this now right so I'm gonna
have these little brackets at the front
and then these really long brackets at
the end what's in the front
it'll be a minus B but what am I and B
in this case they are x and C so instead
of writing a minus B I'm gonna write X
minus C that that's not a coincidence is
it right because I've got that somewhere
else I'll come to that in a minute once
I've written my whole numerator okay you
see it okay now I want to do the rest of
my expansion here so instead of my aides
and B's
I've got X's and C's right yeah very
good X to the power of n minus one
that's here do you see it sign unfold
here right there's the first one what's
the next one okay so I'm gonna have one
less of these X's and then there's gonna
be a well in this case yeah my my B is
equal to C so it's not one less X and
one more C okay good next one yeah one
less X again bless you and then one more
C so instead of C the power of one C
square very good okay very good
how long do I keep going for this now
the question is it depends based on how
big n is right but that's why I mean I I
kind of say you know what you could do
this for any number of n for N equals
two or three or four or like a hundred
and you're just gonna keep on going
until you get to this point so I'm gonna
write dot dot dot what will my very last
term be
C ^ n minus 1 all of the exes are gone
they've all like gone down down down
down down disappeared and then you get
left with this last guy which is the
letter C to have n minus 1 you
absolutely must write that dot dot dot
because what it indicates is hey hey
this pattern it keeps going I don't know
how it keeps going for but it just it
just keeps going till you get to this
okay now even though I was long and
gross that's just the numerator what's
on the denominator Thank You X minus C
okay then you're like whoa this is what
we try to do with these gross limit
things for the whole time right I can't
just put in C equals x you can't do it
because then what happens here what
happens on the denominator if C we're
equal to take you get zero I can't
divide by zero but this point here
through this magical expansion
factorization right you have this kid
selling happening on the top and bottom
do you see that okay so I know it's a
long thing to write out but it's really
important that we do it I've got the
limit it's still there but the top and
the bottom X minus a there they're gone
now
they're just canceled out okay so all
that leaves me with is this gross long
looking thing here but I do need to
write it all out X to the N minus one X
to the N minus 2c keeps going down right
X mile to the N minus three how many C's
two of them and it just keeps on going
its merry way until it gets to the end
like so right okay I generally think
that's a really good spot to have
because you want to establish this
pattern your X's are going down your C's
are going up and in this exact way
freeze generally regarded as a good
number to set up a pen I'll talk a bit
more about later on why that's why three
and not some other number okay all right
now can you be favor just turn back for
a second so the first time we were doing
this all of this limit stuff and we had
the limit as X approaches zero just turn
back to them the the most recent time
where you've got that working in your
book okay now just you might have to
turn a few pages
yeah that'll do okay now anyway you've
got that hopefully you see we do all of
this work while that limited out there
the front until such a time as we could
say oh now I can actually let H equal
zero right it's like oh I don't have h
on the denominator more I could just put
in X equal zero and it doesn't cause me
any problems right so just have a look
that's what we do right so that's the
point we've come to right now you're
like oh I don't have a denominator
anymore I can actually say not just what
happens when C gets close to X what if C
actually became X right so now turn back
to your current page what we do we have
a whole lot of X's and a whole lot of
C's but watch what happens right I'm now
going to this is what we call evaluate
the limit right I'm going to say what
happens when C actually becomes X we're
going to do it term by term I'll jump in
colors just to make it a little more
obvious this X to the N minus 1 what
happens to that when C becomes X it has
no C's in it right so he's like I don't
I don't care I'm still just gonna be X
to the N minus 1 just like I was before
okay but then when you have a look at
this next guy here it does change let's
just look at that one term okay so it
starts with X to the N minus 2 but then
see that that let us see I can just
treat it as if it were X so I'm gonna
write C anyone gonna write X okay let's
keep going along have a look at this guy
here right
it starts with X to the N minus 3 but
then instead of saying C squared I can
treat it as x squared right because what
I'm doing is I've seen are now I can
treat C as it gets towards X I can just
replace it with X I then say oh I've
established the pattern Dada
say that again sorry we do yeah go back
and have a look not right now
but you do we do okay and what's the
very last term what's the real axis yeah
we just we just talked it out
but look yes you've got this it's
completely symmetrical right now I can
just think about this with index laws
right this X to the N minus 1 things at
the front what happens here this is X to
the N minus 2 10 X to the 1 what happens
when you multiply two numbers of the
same base what do you do with the powers
you add them thank you very much
you add them think carefully right
what's n minus 2 plus 1 what n minus 3
plus 2 and then you know what you get a
whole bunch of them right and your last
time is now this is the last important
question right how many of these things
do I have now hold that thought how many
did I have here I had two how many did I
have here I had three how many did I
have here four how many do I have here I
have n of them I have n of these things
so therefore my final line is how many
of these things do I have n of them
times X to the N minus one right now I
that was a lot of work right that was a
lot of work but what you've just proven
is that you can have not just X cubed
not just x squared not just X to the
four for any power of X you never need
to use first principles again you can
just use this we've just established we
have proved our conjecture not through
like I think I saw it happen a lot of
times it seems to this seems to be a
pattern right this is not a just Isis I
seem to see a pattern over and over
again it's proof it's true forever okay
so this is our F dash X this is our rule
that we thought was true before but now
we know it's true when we know why okay